do you have a secret you've never told
me yeah gotcha how do you mean everyone
has secrets and they all replied to
quickly hey youtubers it's Charlie and
welcome to my Sherlock Q&A for sine of
three everyone had a ton of questions so
I picked 20 and tried to combine as many
answers as possible there were a lot of
questions that were very similar there
are also a lot of questions about
episode 3 as well as the fate of Mary
and a lot of other things that I'm gonna
save for my breakdown video I'll try to
post that video on Wednesday be sure to
subscribe to get it that will include
everything like references to the books
or specific things or little plot
details that kind of give us clues about
what's going to be happening next also
heads up a lot of the TV shows that I
normally do videos for are starting to
come back so my video schedule is gonna
start to get back to normal pretty soon
since this video is all about answering
specific questions about plot details
and characters and things that happened
during the sign of 3 if you haven't seen
the episode yet be careful for major
spoilers so a lot of stuff to get
through let's get started question
number one
Ian McGregor asks please explain how the
murder knife worked so Jonathan small
aka the wedding photographer aka
the mayfly man used a very thin knife to
stab both bainbridge that person from
the case of the bloody Guardsman and
major Sholto at the wedding he did it
through their belts so the knife was
super fine that means it was just super
super sharp because of that they didn't
feel it when he stabbed them the idea is
that he would basically stab them and
they would bleed slowly internally until
they died question number 2 Jake Bamford
Ellison asks why do you think it was
Mycroft that was helping Sherlock in his
mind palace instead of Watson Sherlock
manifested Mycroft and said because
either consciously or subconsciously he
thought that Mycroft was the best person
to help him deduce the mayfly man
remember Sherlock has already
demonstrated that he thinks Mycroft is
smarter than he is you know as seen
during empty hearse so his mind was just
summoning the smartest person he could
think of question number 3 Matthew
Staton asks was the main villain of the
series in the book if you're talking
about Jonathan small you know Lord
stabbington then yes he's based on a
character named small in the book the
sign of 4 which is what the episode is
loosely inspired by if you're talking
about the villain Charles Augustus
Magnussen then no he wasn't part of the
original story the sign of 4 he is
referenced briefly during Sherlock's
wedding speech when he's reading off all
those cards
question number four milena Torres asks
do you think the end of episode three
will be a cliffhanger for season four
yes I do
when Benedict Cumberbatch and Martin
Freeman signed on for series three they
also signed on for series four I'll talk
mostly about the plot of his last vow
whenever I do my videos for that episode
next week but yes we are guaranteed a
classic Sherlock style cliffhanger
question number five Flynn Robinson asks
what do you think the connection between
marry and the main villain Charles
Augustus Magnussen is so I'll talk more
about this in greater detail during my
breakdown video but for now I'll just
say that when Sherlock was reading the
notes from the people at the wedding one
of the notes was from the villain you
can either watch that scene and try and
guess what I'm talking about or just you
know wait for my breakdown video on
Wednesday but the fact that the main
villain sent Watson and Mary a note at
their wedding should tell you just how
connected she is to him question number
six the Sherlock tavataa asks how do you
think that Sherlock will handle being
isolated since the sign of three does
not include him so you're asking about
what's going to happen to Sherlock now
that Watson has a wife and a baby
remember how Sherlock carried Watson
around in his head for those two years
while he was away when he was solving
crimes with Molly you know he kept
talking to Watson in his mind palace the
same thing will happen here Sherlock
will still talk to the two of them as if
they're always in the room with him and
his vow was that he would always protect
them so he will have to be involved with
their lives on some level short answer
yes you know Sherlock is going to be
very lonely and he'll talk to mind
Palace Watson a lot but Watson and Mary
both consider Sherlock part of their
family so they're not gonna cut him out
completely question number 7 fangirl
1502 asks how will Sherlock's last vow
tie into the last episode the vow
implied that he would die for the three
of them if need be and he'd stop at
nothing to protect them so I think that
he'll end up in a situation that the
mine palace can't help him solve he'll
have to make a choice that will mean the
death of one character over the other
whether it's his own death or Mycroft or
Watson's or Mary's you know who knows
more to that though Martin Freeman and
Benedict Cumberbatch have both signed
contracts for series four meaning that
they're gonna come back so they're
probably not gonna die in this third
episode question number 8
Mahmood look Navi asks what are the true
intentions of Mary and is she good or
bad what about news for series four so
Mary is a good character but remember
when Sherlock deduced her it said that
she was disillusioned she probably has
the wrong eye
about a certain person that will be very
you know critical in that third episode
so no she's not evil as for series 4 we
really don't know anything about the
plot but we do know that both actors
have signed on I will be doing a
predictions video next week after
episode 3 airs though
question number 9 fruity game asks is it
the murder game so you're actually
asking about the question that I asked
you guys during my review video you know
the game that I was gonna start playing
at parties no that was actually drunk
deductions I will be playing drunk
deductions at the next party that I go
to just think of it now
Aggie chair city thing question number
10 Solaris 290 asks were you surprised
to see Donovan yes she was not available
for filming whenever they made episode 1
but the interesting thing is is that all
those scenes at the beginning of the
episode happened around the time that
Sherlock came back there were about six
months between the events of that
episode which took place in November and
this episode which took place in May so
Donovan was around whenever it all that
stuff was going on during episode 1 but
the interesting thing is that you don't
see her in present-day in this episode
and you don't see Anderson maybe they're
just off doing it again like they were
during study in pink who knows
question number 11 in flora 3722 asks
why is Mycroft wearing a wedding ring
you have a good eye when we see micro
off talking to Sherlock we see a wedding
ring on his right hand
most Western cultures wear wedding rings
on the left hand and Mark Gatiss has
said very clearly on his Twitter that
Mycroft is not married there's all kinds
of things that a ring on the right hand
could mean it could just be a family
heirloom or just a sign of commitment
Mark Gatiss did say that it was a very
intentional choice by the production
team but he would not say exactly what
it meant something really interesting to
think about though is that Anthea also
has a ring on her right hand so let the
theories fly question number 12
Christine Samarra asks why was the
episode called sign of three so the plot
was inspired by elements from the sign
of four book and a lot of the character
names like small and major Sholto that
book involved this really convoluted
treasure plot that Mary Morstan got tied
up in so obviously a lot of aspects of
that story got changed question number
13 Mary Sol asada asks is Mary standing
in front of the horns foreshadowing it
makes it look like they're coming out of
her head so this actually means a couple
things it's a reference to her being a
bit of a trickster she was playing both
Sherlock and Watson to get them
out of the house so she could plan that
wedding I also think that it's a general
ominous warning that there's some sort
of supernatural aspect to her character
when I say supernatural I just mean that
her character is much larger than what
the story has presented her as so far
good I though that was actually one of
the most difficult moments of the
episode with that big thumbs up she gave
question number 14 Wensley talleyrand
asks will we see more of Sherlock in the
bridesmaid only in hetero fanfiction
their final scene where she said I wish
you weren't the way you were and he said
you know me too just means that they're
both acknowledging that they're never
going to be a thing Sherlock is just way
too Sherlock for his own good
if you search tumblr though I'm sure you
could probably find at least a little
bit sherlock bridesmaid fanfic question
number 15 sis say
did red beard mean when Mycroft was
talking to Sherlock on the phone so
Mycroft was talking about the end of an
era red beard and his brother were
pirates together and after his brother
died red beard continued the tradition
of being a pirate
so Mycroft was just telling Sherlock
that he'd always be there for him and
after the loss of Watson who you know
it's kind of like Sherlock's brother
Sherlock would have to carry on his work
alone I guess you could also take that
to mean that Sherlock has a bit of a
pirate too
question number 16 Devin's toss by asks
do you think we'll see that one
character from the mine palace again in
this series no not this series but
possibly another cameo next series
during series 4 but she'll never be
completely gone as long as she's
rattling around naked and Sherlock's
head question number 17 who a girl asks
will you do more Sherlock videos when it
airs again in the United States yes I
will definitely be doing more Sherlock
videos they'll be different from the
videos that I'm doing right now they'll
just be a little bit different but
they'll still be fun and I might even do
a giveaway question number 18
Maria Vasa asks what's up with Mary
shirt so you're talking about the thumbs
up shirt that was really funny and
really weird I think that it was just
meant to be funny from a visual
standpoint it just reinforced the idea
that Mary thinks of herself is a bit of
a trickster she would have had to have
chosen that shirt on purpose knowing
full well that she was giving them that
thumbs up while she was wearing it there
are no coincidences on Sherlock
everything has a purpose question number
Yuki AMA asks how do you think Mycroft
would react if he thought Sherlock died
and is Sherlock becoming more social
going to hurt his abilities to solve
crimes
good questions I think that Mycroft
would feel a
approximation of sadness Mark Gatiss his
version of the character is a lot warmer
than the book version he's a lot nicer
but he wouldn't cry and yes I do think
that Sherlock's ability to solve crimes
will be affected now that he's so you
know emotionally involved with Watson
marry and their baby I think a lot more
of that will tie in with a plot of
episode three Sherlock being super
connected with these people now question
number 20 and last one
ether says Sherlock is starting to
explore the characters emotions way too
much and is focusing less on the puzzle
solving you know course strain of the
character itself you actually had a
really epic comment so high fives
emotional Sherlock was actually a pretty
common complaint I saw in the comments
from you guys so I'll say that yes this
series more so than in previous series
the character has swung back and forth
to both ends of the emotional spectrum
and it's been profoundly weird in empty
hearse he was completely disconnected
from Watson in a human sense and now the
three or you know four of them depending
on how you look at it are turning into
this family unit there was actually an
anime episode that I just did a video
for and the title of it was once more
with feeling which kind of made me think
of this as like Sherlock once more with
feeling what I think we'll see in
Episode three is that you know emotional
pendulum swing back to the middle so in
that first episode he's gone from super
detached to super attached in this
episode and by the end of series three I
think we'll see him kind of return back
to that middle ground where he's that
Sherlock that you're really looking for
so thank you so much everyone for
submitting your questions this was a ton
of fun I'll be posting that breakdown
video by Wednesday be sure to subscribe
to get it
that'll go into a lot of the contextual
clues that will give us an idea for
where episode 3 and maybe even series
four is going remember that nothing on
Sherlock is a coincidence from the
things that they say the clothes they
wear even the way that scenes are filmed
right now you can click here to get my
review of episode 2 and you can click
here to get my breakdown of episode 1
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
you